[Music]
this is springvale
there must be some the sister from the
cathedral puts use your elemental sight
oh hey what do you think this
it looks like a broken tree branch
oh my nose it's from a frame of a wing
glider
therefore hmm a strip of cloth with
animal markings on it looking at the
design and the way it's woven there's a
good chance it came from a wing glider
wow outriders have to be textile experts
now it's a harder job than my mom
thought
if this really belongs to raptor it must
mean his wind glider is broken
how do we know if this was left animal
slimes are airborne creatures they don't
leave marks on the ground
unless someone's hmm either way let's
make a mental
it appears that the elemental markings
point this way huh
well there's only one come on we
oh what's that it sounds like there's a
battle go quick
right
thank goodness the knights of fivonius
have arrived what happened
hilly charles it's a small camp not too
far from the villa but today
oh it really riled them up they chased i
managed to get away but
they smashed my fruit carts to smith
was holding on to something must have
been heavy honestly
people like that shouldn't be allowed in
the skies heavy object tell me
did you uh i managed to catch a glimpse
as i seems like a strong oh
and don't worry
suffocate
yes
there's a bunch of funny looking people
too
judging from the type of wind gliders
they've got i'd say this lot is with
raptor
but if that's the case what are they
hanging around here for
i wonder huh look where we are
the elemental power on the art raptor
must have realized the markings went
that way when the effect
he won't get
but we